nueva crisis en la escena política
peruana el presidente martín vizcarra se
enfrentará a un juicio de destitución
por presunta incapacidad moral la moción
fue realizada por el congreso en medio
de acusaciones al mandatario de haber
pedido a sus asesores que mintieran en
una investigación acerca de un polémico
contrato realizado a un cantante
los incendios forestales no dan tregua a
la costa oeste de eeuu si dejan hasta el
momento al menos 25 muertos decenas de
personas desaparecidas y obligan además
a evacuaciones masivas los estados de
california washington y oregón son ahora
el epicentro de las conflagraciones que
ya destruyeron miles de hogares
y después de 19 años del conflicto
comenzaron ya las históricas
negociaciones de paz entre el gobierno
de afganistán y los insurgentes
talibanes
el esperado diálogo intra afgano comenzó
con un pedido de cese del fuego y con la
exigencia de los talibanes de que el
país tenga un sistema político islámico
muy buenos días bienvenidos a las
noticias de france 24 saludamos a
nuestra audiencia muchas gracias por
acompañarnos como cada día comenzamos
esta emisión con noticias de américa
latina y vamos a perú porque el congreso
de este país aprobó someter a un juicio
de destitución al presidente martín
vizcarra y esto por supuesta incapacidad
moral el mandatario está acusado de
haber pedido a sus asesores que
mintieran en una investigación
parlamentaria sobre un polémico contrato
presuntamente cargado de irregularidades
por parte del ministerio de cultura
peruano al cantante de richter swing
quien fue conferencista y animador en
diversos actos oficiales ahora el
congreso peruano deberá votar en un
pleno extraordinario antes de los
próximos 10 días si mantiene o no al
presidente en su cargo quien por su
parte tendrá una hora de alegatos ante
los congresistas desde el hima de la
capital peruana nuestro corresponsal
francisco zacarías no se ampliaba la
información
para el congreso peruano martín vizcarra
mintió obstaculizó a la justicia
manipuló testigos adúltero pruebas y le
ordenó a sus colaboradoras mentirle a la
fiscalía y no solamente a esta
institución sino también al mismo
parlamento para encubrir las visitas del
cantante a richard swing al palacio de
gobierno quien venía siendo investigado
por probable actos de corrupción al
haber sido favorecido con contratos de
asesorías al ministerio de cultura de
cultura y por los que recibió un pago de
50 mil dólares para los congresistas en
los audios compromete muy seriamente en
actos ilícitos al presidente de martín
vizcarra y lo hace merecedor a ser
restituido por incapacidad moral por lo
pronto la ministra de justicia ha
anunciado que el gobierno del presidente
de martín vizcarra va a optar dos
estrategias la principal es interponer
una demanda competencial contra el
congreso ante el tribunal constitucional
para que sea esta máxima corte la que
defina si procede o no que el parlamento
lo destituya por incapacidad moral una
segunda vía es plantear una demanda
ante un juzgado esta es una medida
cautelar para que la corté interponga
una paralización a cualquier tipo de
acción del parlamento para el presidente
de martín vizcarra los audios no
constituyen ni un hecho delictivo y todo
se trataría más bien según su opinión de
un complot para sacarlo de la
presidencia un complot que él mismo ha
señalado está dirigido por algunos
congresistas y opositores a su gobierno
seguimos con más noticias de américa
latina' porque bogotá a la capital de
colombia vivió su tercera jornada de
protestas en contra de la violencia
policial aunque esta vez de una manera
más pacífica pese a los conatos de
disturbios donde los manifestantes
denunciaron nuevamente abusos por parte
de los uniformados y luego del pedido de
perdón que realizaron el gobierno
nacional y la policía por las agresiones
ocurridas durante los dos primeros días
de manifestación es uno de los
epicentros de las protestas fue el
barrio villaluz donde precisamente
trabajan los dos uniformados que mataron
brutalmente al abogado javier ordóñez
sobre quien descargaron una pistola
teaser en ocho oportunidades en un hecho
que encendió las protestas callejeras
que han dejado al momento 13 muertos y
más de 400 heridos
para el domingo la alcaldesa de bogotá a
claudia lópez convocó a un acto de
reconciliación y perdón para reconstruir
la confianza
y en otras noticias la ong human rights
watch arremetió contra el gobierno
interino de bolivia al asegurar que la
acusación por supuesto terrorismo que
abrió contra el ex presidente evo
morales no es proporcional por lo que
debe ser retirada y además destacó que
el ejecutivo transitorio utiliza el
sistema judicial para perseguir a los
partidarios del ex mandatario morales la
administración de la presidenta interina
jeanine áñez negó que haya persecución y
señaló además que todos los procesos se
basan en argumentos jurídicos los
detalles en el informe de valentina
torre sánchez
una clara persecución contra el ex
presidente evo morales y sus seguidores
esto es de lo que la ong human rights
watch acusa al gobierno interino de
bolivia gobierno actual interino de
bolivia abusa del sistema de justicia
para perseguir a colaboradores y a
partidarios del ex presidente evo
morales quien enfrenta cargos por
terrorismo que a la luz de las pruebas
parecen responder más bien a
motivaciones políticas de acuerdo con la
organización la acusación contra morales
por terrorismo es desproporcional y debe
ser retirada asimismo indica que en
bolivia se ve un abuso de poder en casos
específicos su gobierno ha presionado de
forma pública a fiscales y jueces para
que actúen de manera favorable a sus
objetivos dando lugar a investigaciones
penales contra más de 100 personas
vinculadas
al gobierno de evo morales o
simpatizantes por supuestos delitos de
sedición o terrorismo el ejecutivo negó
categóricamente lo afirmado por la ong
un ex presidente ordenó cercar la ciudad
no permitir el paso de alimento a un
país que él mismo gobernaba y llamaba a
su pueblo todo por un simple afán de
poder los abogados que prepararon la
denuncia solventaron argumentos
jurídicos para denunciar a evo morales
por terrorismo el informe se presenta
días después de que la presidenta
interina jan y meañés reiterará que si
morales vuelve a bolivia enfrentará a
las órdenes emitidas por la fiscalía
para comparecer por varios procesos en
su contra mientras tanto los incendios
forestales no dan tregua a la costa
oeste de eeuu y obligan a masivas
evacuaciones los estados de california
washington y oregón están sufriendo una
ola de devastadora conflagraciones que
ya destruyeron miles de hogares oregón
se convirtió ahora en el último
epicentro de
los incendios que dejan en el momento 25
muertos una cifra que podría ir
aumentando con el paso de las horas dado
que se han reportado decenas de
desapariciones en los tres estados
france24 pudo dialogar con mario picazo
él es meteorólogo en the weather network
y el tiempo de españa' acerca del avance
de estos incendios y también sobre cómo
combatirlos en este contexto tan
particular de pandemia y esto nos decía
y aquí lo que tenemos que preocuparnos
ahora mismo es sobretodo de las labores
de extinción cómo podemos hacer para que
estos incendios no se propaguen sean
cuales sean las condiciones atmosféricas
se hace más viento hay una ola de calor
o lo que sea lógicamente lo que se trata
de la gestión del monte ya pasó se tenía
que haber hecho mejor durante la
primavera y el invierno pero este año ha
sido especial sobre todo por la
situación del cob y no ha habido tantos
medios para cuidar el monte para
protegernos de los incendios y por lo
tanto ahora se trata sobre todo de tener
recursos humanos para luchar contra esos
ingenios cosa que también es complicada
por la situación del cob y porque este
año se puede contar con tanta gente con
otros años y por lo tanto los recursos
humanos no son los suficientes en cuanto
al futuro de todos estos incendios nos
va a tener un impacto tremendo
directamente pues por supuesto porque
esto sin tener se están generando mucho
humo esas nubes de humo lo que hacen es
de alguna forma bloquear la radiación
solar pues aquí anticipamos que este
sería como una gran erupción volcánica
podría haber un enfriamiento durante los
próximos meses pero a la vez también
sabemos que algunas de las partículas
que generan estos incendios pueden
provocar calentamiento ahí todavía
estamos investigando
cuál de los dos pesa más por otra parte
habrá un impacto tremendo en la
superficie y cuatro días después del
devastador incendio que arrasó con el
campo de refugiados de moria ubicado en
la isla griega de lesbos miles de
desplazados que se quedaron sin sus
techos fueron reprimidos por la policía
griega en una nueva protesta que tuvo
lugar precisamente en un campamento que
se está erigiendo en la isla los más de
12.000 refugiados piden al gobierno
griego salir de la isla y ser
trasladados a la parte continental del
país mientras continúan las tareas para
la construcción de un nuevo albergue que
según el propio ministro de migración de
grecia recibiría hoy mismo a los
primeros refugiados
[Música]
y después de 19 años de conflicto
comenzaron en doha la capital catarí
unos históricos diálogos de paz entre
los representantes del gobierno de
afganistán que piden un alto al fuego y
los insurgentes talibanes- que por su
parte exigen un sistema político
dinámico el secretario de estado de eeuu
mike y pompeo encabezó la primera
jornada de diálogos instando a las
partes a aprovechar esta oportunidad
para hacer la paz una histórica
oportunidad de paz en uno de los
conflictos más letales del mundo este
sábado iniciaron las conversaciones
entre el ejecutivo afgano y los
talibanes en presencia del secretario de
estado de eeuu may pompeo
soy consciente y sé que todos ustedes
también lo están que sin duda
encontraremos muchos desafíos durante
las conversaciones en los próximos días
semanas y meses cuando esto pase
recuerde que no sólo está actuando por
esta generación de afganos sino también
por las generaciones futuras sus hijos
julio verne el objetivo es poner fin a
un conflicto armado que ha dejado más de
100.000 muertos durante la última década
pero que lleva casi 20 años cobrando
vidas y sacrificando la estabilidad de
afganistán el negociador del gobierno
agradeció a las partes por su
disposición a negociar y pidió que se
detengan los combates uy sí
bien si buscamos que se anuncie un alto
el fuego humanitario el alto el fuego
nos permitirá brindar asistencia
humanitaria y de desarrollo a toda
nuestra gente en todas las regiones de
afganistán
wiggins que está por su parte el
negociador del talibán reiteró su
llamado a la creación de un sistema
islámico como punto de partida para las
conversaciones afganas también el
creemos que a peris tan sea un país
desarrollado independiente y unido y
debería tener una especie de sistema
islámico
la apertura de los diálogos tuvo lugar
un día después del aniversario número 19
de los ataques contra las torres gemelas
y el pentágono que desencadenaron la
intervención militar
estadounidense en afganistán el gobierno
de donald trump quiere poner fin al
conflicto más largo del país mientras
busca la reelección el próximo 3 de
noviembre continuamos ahora con
información sobre el avance de el
coronavirus kobe 1910 que el continente
americano ya tiene más de la mitad de
los contagios y de las muertes
provocadas en todo el mundo el
continente ya pasó los 500 mil
fallecidos estados y nuevos con eeuu
continúa a la cabeza con más de 6
millones 400 mil casos positivos y más
de 193.000 muertos mientras tanto en
américa latina brasil tiene más de
4.200.000 casos en las últimas 24 horas
sobrepasó los 130 mil fallecidos pero
por su parte tiene más de 716 mil
contagios y 30.000 muertes mientras que
colombia continúa bajando el número de
casos diarios y ya alcanzó los 700 mil y
registra más de 22 mil decesos mientras
que méxico ocupa el quinto lugar en el
continente con más de 650 mil casos
positivos pero es el cuarto país de todo
el mundo con más muertes superando las
70 mil
y el primer lote de la vacuna rusa
sputnik 5 contra el hobbit 19 ya fue
enviado a varias regiones del país esto
fue anunciado en la noche del viernes
por el ministerio de salud y en el marco
de esta entrega piloto se van a aprobar
las cadenas logísticas del suministro de
la vacuna a las regiones de rusia
también su distribución y la
organización de la vacunación para los
ciudadanos que integran el grupo de
riesgo elevado y desde moscú la capital
rusa en nuestro corresponsal
xavier colás nos amplía la información
la noticia se ha conocido mientras
muchos rusos dormían los primeros lotes
de la vacuna rusa contra el coronavirus
llamado sputnik 5 y han partido rumbo a
algunas regiones de rusia se trata de
una experiencia piloto para comprobar la
cadena de logística de la red de
distribución y sobre todo para ir
preparando este amplio proceso de
vacunación de millones de rusos según
las autoridades rusas la vacuna ofrece
una inmunidad de en torno a dos años
los primeros en recibirla serán la
población de mayor riesgo
fundamentalmente los sanitarios y
también los profesores sin embargo
muchos rusos no están viviendo con
especial entusiasmo el proceso que ahora
comienza y según las estadísticas casi
la mitad de los rusos no tienen ninguna
intención de ponerse esta vacuna no
porque teman los efectos de la espuma y
5 sino porque creen que el riesgo del
coronavirus ha sido magnificado y
exagerado por los medios de comunicación
mientras tanto las autoridades rusas
aseguran que fuera del país hay mucho
interés en su vacuna en torno a 20
países tan interesados en recibir mil
millones de dosis
y nuevamente los chalecos amarillos
salen a las calles de parís y las
manifestaciones ya dejan 23 personas
detenidas antes incluso del inicio de la
marcha oficial y tras el veto de
manifestación en los campos elíseos
donde las autoridades temen escenas de
violencia
finalizamos otra emisión informativa
quédense con nosotros hay muchísimo más
en el resto de nuestra programación y en
france24 punto com
[Música]